welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the falcon of the winter
soldier just dropped a new trailer and
for any of you worried that marvel going
forward is all
genre bending what the [ __ ] i don't know
why you'd worry about that i personally
love
it the falcon of the winter soldier by
comparison is like a boom boom yeah
fast like in the spirit of lethal weapon
and the fast and the furious
fun fact bucky's scream actually
translates to hello girl kick your ass
i'm gonna break down this trailer shot
by shot because there are actually some
insane visual clues telling us how this
series is going to connect not just to
avengers end game in one division but
the future marvel titles like secret
invasion and
x-men and these cap team-up movies that
are being announced let's get started
so who would like to start
mr barnes why does sam aggravate you
15 seconds to drop so what's our plan
hey great okay we opened on this
hilarious couple counseling scene
they are an unusual couple you know
but notice the music let's get this
jarring synthy scream
actually my breakdown last year of
captain america winter soldier i pointed
out how the winter soldier music was
composed using this distorted scream
to make that sound the composer
literally screamed in his studio and
used that distorted it stretched it out
kind of like graded it over metal all as
a way to na do bucky's inner torment
dating back to his scream and that fall
from the train in the first cap film
when he fell into hydra's clutches
so this is the scream of bucky's buried
rage from being brainwashed by hydra
into a killing machine
by the way one division is currently
showing wanda dealing with a similar
hydra induced trauma but this opening
clip syncs that sound effect with sam
diving out of the cargo plane
and in doing so sam is evoking cap from
winter soldier
is he wearing a parachute no
no he wasn't next clip superheroes
cannot be allowed to exist
[Music]
i have no intention to leave my work
unfinished
all right we glide into this asian city
this is madrapore a fictional setting
for the marvel comics located near real
life singapore it's a haven for
criminals in the marvel universe
there is a huge wealth gap super rich
crime lords and the towering skyscrapers
and
the bottom feeders in the street level
drug dens you can see the same kind of
disparity in the vessels in the harbor
massive luxury yachts and more modest
fishing boats
madrapore like places like sokovia and
wakanda is the latest new fictional
setting on earth being explored in the
mcu
in the comics it is ties to the x-men
and wolverine as well as to the hand
the enemies of daredevil and iron fist
this is really exciting that we're going
there but now that one division appears
to be bringing in
quick silver from the fox x-men universe
the mcu might have more of a multiverse
explanation in mind for how
mutants are coming into the mcu there's
a couple other explanations for what's
going on there i got a whole other video
coming out about it tomorrow keep an eye
out for it
zemo now carrying his iconic purple mask
continues his plot to wipe out
superheroes from civil war but how did
he escape from captivity well perhaps
the blip because wandavision just showed
us that the snap's reversal without
warning
resulted in total chaos across the
universe if a hospital could be suddenly
overrun
so could whatever prison facility zemo
was being kept in
actually remember the last trailer
showed a shot of what looked like a
simmering prison riot
guards overwhelmed that could have been
that post-split moment
another possibility could have been
released by thunderbolt ross and some
plot by ross to create a thunderbolts
team of anti-heroes
similar to zemo's citizen the arc in the
thunderbolts comics we'll see if they
end up going that direction but here
zemo stands at a sokovia memorial statue
think about it everyone else in the
world just got reunited with their lost
loved ones from the blip but not zemo
his family remains dead like wanda
dealing with vision's death everyone who
died right up until the moment of that
snap stays dead unfortunately
except loki he's always the exception of
the rule let's move on
the wall's upside down right now
where do we start here bucky going by
amc ball cap rules has the best
disguise no one's gonna recognize him
he's watching this military
awards ceremony now i'm thinking this
could be the moment john walker gets
promoted to
us agent and gets the shield notice how
sam wears a non-military suit and he
looks wistfully from the shield to cap's
exhibit in the smithsonian
he may be forced to participate in the
ceremony to take the shield from the
exhibit and hand it over begrudgingly to
this unworthy successor this series
appears to be focusing on the legacy of
captain america carl lumbley was
actually cast in an unknown role and
many believe it's going to be the
historical black cap isaiah bradley an
african-american test subject for the
super soldier serum before it was given
to steve rogers during world war ii
a guy who had this whole other history
that no one ever gave its proper due
and maybe now sam has to grapple with
that history of black erasure also if
lumberley is
isaiah bradley that could set up a
younger actor to play his grandson
elijah bradley the young avenger patriot
also i love this but notice how sam
looks up to the mural of cap that is to
the left of him
always on your left come on here i love
how the editing syncs up sam's shield
toss with bucky's catch kind of like
these two buds are just tossing a
frisbee makes it feel like great
teamwork you know bucky's catch and
recoil kind of evokes caps catch and
recoil of mjolnir and in-game but this
video was sponsored by
sheath underwear it's boxers that are
designed to keep your bits
gently separated for maximum comfort
let's get a peek under the hood on these
bad boys so
sheath has three individual compartments
to keep everything down
there separate cool and comfortable you
know you got your this
and you got your that see traditional
boxer briefs just throw
everything all together like that mean
lunch lady who just haphazardly slaps
your beef stroganoff right on top of
your fruit cup
sheath has a modern ergonomic design
intended to prevent hot sweaty skin
on skin contact sheath is like the kind
lunch lady who made sure your peas and
mashed potatoes stayed separate
there's this inverted kangaroo pouch for
your joey to cut down on chafing and
readjusting these were actually invented
by a us army soldier who came up with
the idea for sheath during his second
tour in iraq where it is hot as hell
and his boys needed to breathe so he
invented this comfortable underwear to
keep your
boys cool and comfortable and leaving
room for jesus to keep them from kissing
so click the link below and use the code
new rockstars at check out and go to
sheath underwear dot com slash
new rockstars for 20 off and do your
boy's favorite that's uh
sheath underwear dot com slash new
rockstars or click on that link below
and use the code new rockstars for
20 off next clip
i have a plan oh yeah what is it
is you ready here we go again huh we've
been grinding hard on the dog
here this club's painting collection
includes van gogh's famous self-portrait
that belongs in a museum
i wonder if during the blip looters
could have stolen famous art from
museums and then it all ended up in the
hands of rich collectors like this
sam says he has a plan in this great
close-up that matches the framing of
iron man's hud close-ups now it's not
sure what sam's plan
is though this mission looks like he and
bucky had to liberate this plane from
combatants first
so they might be stealing it or stealing
whatever's on it or stealing back from
the hijackers and sharon carter is
confirmed to be back from civil war so
glad to have her back especially since
she is at the top of my list of hidden
government scrolls in the mcu why am i
bringing up scrolls well
you'll see in the next clip
okay huge detail from this section this
wall of skulls
and the reaction to me these kind of
looked a bit ape-like but then i have
realized guys
these are scroll heads huh so whoever
runs this club
they hunt scrolls and they use their
heads for freaking decoration
awesome so the secret invasion is
brewing folks
people know scrolls exist and they don't
like them
squirrels showed up on jimmy wu's notes
in wandavision so we know the war that
is coming now i love how sam uses his
wings as a shield they
fold in over him which begs the question
if falcon's tech is
this awesome and functional does he
really need cap shield that's why i hope
he gets to just stay falcon
but that shield could end up in the
hands of neither bucky nor sam
but really maybe the bradley family and
right before the explosion in the
shipping yard you can see
zemo standing on a crate he is wearing
his purple mask high color coat
four figures are standing below each
with a different look
so zemo is commanding some team in this
series
maybe the mcu's version of the
thunderbolts maybe something else we'll
see
hello girl kick your ass
[Music]
okay more shots of this truck sequence
two red trucks maybe some kind of heist
back doors are open there you can see
bucky being restrained on one sam on the
other
as aaron kellerman's character watches
this group is probably her group the
flag smashers based on the cat villain
who wants to unite the world by tearing
down national flag iconography she
jump punches bucky off the side of the
truck and as falcons swoops in under
both trucks it looks as though you can
see him catching bucky there all right
final clip see
that wasn't so hard are you ready is you
ready ready okay
you ready what are you doing ready ready
are you having a staring contest
are you ready just
blank sweet jesus i mean how old
are you so bucky appears to win this
staring contest as the winter soldier he
was brainwashed to like never flinch
i love how when that woman snaps sam
looks over but
bucky doesn't the winter soldier is
frozen
and she jokingly asks how old are you
and i love bucky's response because yeah
he's
old how old well in my reaction my quick
math was 101
since he was born in 1917 and then he
blipped in 2018 making him 101 and then
five years later he didn't age
so assuming this takes place not long
after end game he'd either be like 101
or 102
but this is complicated because remember
most of the 20th century he was on
ice he would just be thought out time to
time by hydra to assassinate
somebody so buggy doesn't really know
how old he is he just knows you super
old maybe upwards of 100.
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow the new rockstars check out
our great merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com subscribe to
rockstars and i will see you next time
bye
[Music]
you